[Musica]
di mestiere scrivo che in realtà vuol
dire tutto o nulla sono una giovane
donna sono anche lavoro da casa lavoro
d'ufficio
ritmi e un pensiero
sono il con o il senza sentirsi con
sentirsi senza se la maestra delle
elementari di allora vi dicesse ora
adesso descrivete v da dove partire ste
forse da bambini eravamo più abituati a
descrivere noi stessi e gli altri
anche oggi non abbiamo particolari
problemi se dobbiamo scrivere una
didascalia un post che dobbiamo
pubblicare ma pensateci a parlare ad
alta voce
pronunciarlo ad alta voce avremo
problemi
ecco io comincio da questa foto
descrivendomi
allora qui io il viso ovale
però forse dovrei chiedere aiuto ai
consulenti di immagine
poi gli occhi marroni in questa foto
sono un po socchiusi per fortuna non si
vede il mascara un poco lato poi i
capelli anche questi marroni tendenti ad
amato molto ondulati e tutti appiccicose
ingarbugliati perché non è ancora
imparato a
pettinarli subito dopo il bagno poi le
guance rosse
sempre
365 giorni l'anno
il medico mi dice guarda dovresti curare
dovresti mettere della crema io rispondo
no blush naturale 365 giorni l'anno
poi le labbra in questa foto non si
vedono ma sono secche però simile un
sorriso lievemente accennato la maestra
delle elementari poi ti dice ok va bene
vai avanti però non hai finito la tua
descrizione
e io t'ho intenderei io dico
boh non lo so avrei qualche incertezza
forse posso buttarmi su quel costume a
strisce blu e bianco marinaio con una
stella al centro poi ti ricordi che qui
effettivamente la crema non l'avevi
messa e 15 6 leggermente bruciata e
continuerai con dei puntini di
sospensione
ma quel tempo non l'abbiamo e quindi
andando dritto al punto questo è lo
specchio di te
specchio perché specchio è un oggetto è
un oggetto quadrato rotondo rettangolare
e anche la fotocamera del nostro
cellulare
noi lo viviamo quotidianamente ma è
anche un verbo transitivo specchiare o
specchiarsi riflessivo cosa vuol dire
specchiarsi nell'altro per assumere un
modello per specchiarsi in una dote in
una qualità ma specchio perché perché io
in questa foto mi sento nuda oltre il
costume a righe strisce
bianche e blu a strisce bianche e blu ma
in cui mi sento nuda oltre il costume o
appunto e anche perché è quello è il
presente elogi di una giovane donna è
anche quello che non sono
ma che vorrei essere e anche mi sento
libera di non rispondere a una domanda
quello che forse voi pensate adesso
guarda si punta proprio di e quello che
non c'è è invece qui in questo palco c'è
ma lì mi sento anche libera di giocare
con le parole di sporcarmi sulla sabbia
sono anche il timore l'imbarazzo di
stare lì seduta sulla sabbia per esempio
le domande dire ok ma lì si vedono anche
altre cose si vedono dei contorni
sottile quanto è difficile stare su una
spiaggia tutti almeno una volta nella
vita abbiamo trovato imbarazzo magari ci
eravamo troppo arrestati magari il pareo
air sbagliato
ma almeno una volta ci siamo sentiti in
imbarazzo
sono anche dei contorni sottili appunto
o sono anche le affermazioni ma se non
si vedono con le cose
sulle mani o li proprio non si vedono 6
tranquilla ma guarda che è pieno di
influenze ma cosa dici cosa farai
macchia macchia che è qualcosa che
provoca un guasto che è imperfezione che
è difetto ma sono anche le domande sono
anche dei like sono anche le domande ma
scusa perché non le curie quelle macchie
uno mi scrisse così quando pubblicai
questa foto su su instagram e risposi no
per ora no le ho provate tutte le cure
non funzionano ma pensiamo anche
all'utilizzo figurativo magari della
parola macchia avrete sentito il
cavaliere senza macchia e senza paura il
cavaliere qui non è rivelato a prenderla
sua principessa però il cavaliere senza
macchia quindi senza imperfezioni e se e
senza timore
le parole danno un senso le parole
raccontano la realtà ma lo decidiamo noi
come prima e dopo quindi macchia senza
con il famoso specchio
decidiamo di essere prima come cd
scriviamo prima come cd scriviamo adesso
il presente e come ci descriviamo dopo
mi è successo molte volte di essere
descritta dagli altri con particolari
parole con particolari senza e con
particolari non ero sempre descritta con
il nome certo a volte con qualche refuso
al maschile aggiungendo una ola
raggiungendo una flavia aggiungendo una
fabiola a volte il
lavoro la professione non era nemmeno
inserita molte volte
e poi invece la cosa più scontata era
sempre il senza ok avete capito come
prima cosa inserita alla prima alla
prima riga di ogni descrizione di ogni
biografia ma il problema è che appunto
lo decidiamo noi cosa essere prima e
cosa essere dopo perché perché in quel
momento io ci sono rimasta male e ci
rimango male sempre perché la
descrizione e altro oltre un nome la
professione è la descrizione magari di
un percorso abbastanza lungo dove
potersi arrabbiare è la descrizione di
una sala d'attesa con i muri asettici è
la descrizione di non avere una risposta
magari e della descrizione di stare
all'interno di una casa all'interno di
una camera davanti a quello specchio e
dire ok vai piano c'è tempo per dire
accettati non preoccuparti stai lì ferma
seduta non ti manda via nessuno
ma lo decido io decido io cosa
comunicare di me e dobbiamo fare
attenzione
quindi se non vi dispiace ora io vorrei
rimanere un attimo su quella spiaggia
che ora non c'è più e
almeno per un altro po
vedersi con vedersi senza con cicatrici
sono tatuaggi diversi senza un aggiungi
metti togli di pennellata la giornata da
un'ora da un minuto con parole che
dicono e io l'ho vostro vista così e mi
sembra proprio strano dice una bambina
ciao dico io quella è solo una parte del
tutto
vorrei dire è solo apparenza e con
carola mano bionica non è cambiato
proprio nulla c'è solo uno sguardo forse
diverso più incuriosito di come questa
cosa che funziona proprio così dai va
tutto bene non è solo quella cosa dico
io è anche quello ma non solo quelle sì
che forse vedi sono macchie
dove volevano andare sono andate e
rimangono forse sbiadiscono forse
diventano nove pontini scuri con il
rossore di una giornata al sole con i
capelli disordinati
senza ispirazione senza ei se ce la
faccio io lo puoi anche tu ma con
vedremo domani come va guardali forse ci
vedo un cuore domani forse ricominciamo
da qui immagina come sarebbe andata se a
volte pensi guardati attorno
uno specchio di te
facendo yoga passeggiando ora
galleggiando come quella domenica di
settembre di due anni fa e respirare e
mandare giù
è contare quante volte ti sei sentita
così e forse solo stare qui sola con me
osserva e riconosce quelle sfumature
senza con e ora per chiudere il cerchio
dovrai si finire quel tema e che non ho
finito e
forse giustificarmi o forse rispondere
alla domanda di quella maestra di allora
che poteva potrebbe essere ma scrivi di
che scrivi di cosa scrivi per chi forse
potrei dirle che il mio no non anagramma
e tutto è stato scritto dal destino o
forse
e forse potrei mostrarle questo pezzetto
di carta di molto tempo fa che durante
un laboratorio spessi la mia firma nome
il cognome con la parola autrice e
quindi inserire hong kong e non senza e
quindi essere finalmente quella dei con
grazie
[Applauso]